[Music]
in Tower of Terror news is it well
that's why they have it we should change
it into Disney look at how happy sure
there wasn't it isn't that the elevator
yeah the hotel it changed it I think our
deeds a gals decent right you know so
much about Disney are you a fan
submitted by Amy hi I mean six people
were rescued after an elevator fell 84
floors I know where the focus is
building in Taiwan wait how many floors
that are for me oh my god how many
people were in the elevator China that's
a good question no there were six people
no one got hurt oh wow awesome
that's amazing I think I want to go
again if you live you want to go again
no you don't want the people you love
and you want to pay off back when your
imagine like being like [ __ ]
weightless for like four seconds maybe I
would think about how you feel on a
roller coaster do you feel like you're
gonna die but then you make it and then
you're like oh that was awesome I lived
I want to go again he doesn't feel that
but we all thought scared of that [ __ ] I
don't like I forgot mmm-hmm Oh like
smoked oysters I technically hate roller
coasters but for this bit I'm gonna like
okay yeah well I had I had a dream I was
at Magic Mountain let's make your dreams
come true yeah but in my dream though it
was like in the future and it was crummy
and half of the rides were closed and
then we all were like man how come it's
always closed like Superman's clothes
this is closed the point of you saying
that it was in the future was to tell us
how cool the rider but they're so
cynical everything's [ __ ] close I
mean we were only able to do like gold
rush or like you know those shitty ones
that were like like ninja it's like yeah
that's like in this dream you got a
pretzel they gave you food poisoning
it's uh I found my work dream because
then you can enjoy it now yeah I think
it was cuz you guys were saying how like
Disney and Disney a lot of the rides are
always closed now yeah well though
Indiana Jones is closed and then this is
closed they're gonna it's always not
closed bags always being fixed it's
always being fixed like a lot of the
rides and stuff well you guys talked
about that so I think that came in my
head dude in the 90s I went and I was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me they
closed all of Tomorrowland like the
whole [ __ ] thing was closed because
they're renovating it oh this is
ridiculous did you even care about
smugglin yeah it was the tightest one by
far you don't gotta [ __ ] Frontierland
I love I limit jerk off somewhere good
jerk off funny place isn't is Nina you
get hand jobs at Disney are you out of
your mother get a hand job at Disney I
would say I won't say anything but the
Haunted Mansion you can do all kind of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you can't because they'll
they have cameras and we've actually
been stopped on hope you guys okay now
now okay 90s was the different story how
old were you in the 90s I was eight
years old
okay blade lucky anyway so this elevator
thing here this takes place in Chicago
84 what [ __ ] building so this is that
the former Hancock building that's what
they call it
yeah I don't know they had billing or
merged John Hancock building can I get
to Jeff jank so these people they were
on the 95th floor because that's where
they have this restaurant and then when
they were coming down they fell 84
floors and they were stuck on the 11
damn that's scary
so it didn't stop right on the first
floor thank goodness the brakes worked
or something yeah so what happened was
that there were these two cables that
snap and so they were like
Londyn we even had a whole bunch of
other cables still intact and so that's
why it was safe for them to be rescued
and all that stuff so it wasn't like a
full free-falling like like yeah you
said you imagine them like going up like
yeah like this it was probably just a
really fast fall then right not like
Monica oh [ __ ] you don't mention how
long they were falling they don't
mention if they were even freefall from
these interviews freefall from Magic
Mountain it's it's not like the highest
fall but then whoa that's not darling
thank you but you still feel that
weightlessness for a few seconds I'm
like did you feel your balls go
weightless they don't even ask the right
questions that's like what we have to we
have to we'll do it one day to actually
do it Oh location if you just send you
into this yeah I'm down and then we have
it under Street magic I want to wear a
three-piece suit for a do I'll remember
to have a bag of cookies to make people
feel good to you there you go that was
it scary would you like a cookie I get
to do the interview eat the cookie we're
like both eating cookies and [ __ ] it was
really scary Steve green just kidding
those are just JK cuz that sounds more
like yeah yeah yeah all of our news like
three weeks late
our [ __ ] is live on location we're like
we're here at the fires on Kevin
California it's like well that [ __ ] was
a month ago so it takes time to travel
and then shoot it come back and get it
edited that's true even if it means none
of that did say live
yeah I know we're gonna say it's live
but we're gonna record it on regular
cameras yeah yeah we're just gonna say
it yeah we're just gonna be like live
breaking my location in order to make
this work with me a time machine
yeah see I'd be like I'd be like it
smelled like a toilet but not because
they used it like one because they were
scared shitless back to you guys
but [ __ ] like that that's gonna be sunny
all week today back to you back to you
Jeff
they have a strip back to you Steve
they'll be tired just going back and
forth like that hell yeah
back to you Steve back to you too loving
the weather over there yeah say hey to
everybody over there for me yeah oh hey
keep a cold one for me in the studio
like you always do that [ __ ] of grab-ass
in the movie
yeah you don't have to do that like
these [ __ ] each other's dicks pretty
hard they do you know they're trying to
be more raw these days and make mistakes
and be more human but it's like that
character trying to be real it's [ __ ]
over there yeah it's always like it's
always like well I don't know about you
but that story gave me a boner
you should apologize dude because the
way you talk okay not because of what
you said yeah I don't talk like that I
wonder if they study JK news and try to
be like that I highly doubt it just like
randomly flick some confetti in their
eye so you could see how real they are
you see that I prefer that than them
[ __ ] Howard Cosell everyone does like
just it's always like well very official
when I its the Dodgers playing of the
World Series it's in every country to
and every language they sound the same
yeah yeah even though the Spanish ones
did too
I think they do they're all sound like
really faith like tomo estar muy sunny
today boy son yo some Australian some
Australian broadcast and they didn't
seem quite as fake but maybe it's just
the accident covers it up for me they
were all just chumming and talking like
normal people have you ever heard Hugh
Jackman on Australian TV yes when he's
like interview for x-men over here like
it's like more subtle but when he's over
there he's like four kangaroo is
okay have you guys seen Christian Bale
when he was so when he was first cast as
Batman as the Batman he was on all the
news circuits like doing interviews and
he was talking like he does as Bruce
Wayne not like Christian Bale with an
accent oh really it was in characters
he's like a great or something yeah yeah
so he was held he was talking with like
an English accent all these media hits
because they didn't want controversy
about like a English guy playing Batman
or some [ __ ] like they wouldn't find out
so he was using an American accent even
though he's from the UK Oh weird
so he's like on Howard Stern and Jays
like he's like absolutely he's like yep
that's you know I didn't even realize
that he had an accent I think that's why
yeah he's hiding that's what I'm saying
cuz we knew there during the biggest
press tour when he was in the Batman
movie he did that [ __ ] until you hear
him cussed out that DP on that one clip
I've heard he was going thank you is
going crazy it's like Mel Gibson in
brave hard on this it's you can't I
think it's just the audio file yeah it's
just they let the sound keep rolling it
was British as a [ __ ] on that
thing it's not a fake cuz I'm like not
you you brought a [ __ ] ball ride
there's some [ __ ] like that yeah and
then you have to work with a guy after
that's awkward they should have you know
what some fans told me when I was in
Australia like when we were when I did
like when I did the seminar out there
and all speaking afterwards they were
like when I watched JK news I can't tell
like that you guys have such a thick
accent and then after after the speech
they're like man you really really have
that American accent and I'm like what
oh yeah yeah no you have an accent I
don't have an accent first of all I
don't have an accent no accent we speak
completely clearly
normal sounding people in the whole
world but what one else is weird
but what struck me was that when they're
listening to it to them it doesn't
register as an accent it's like it's
just content right but then when they
when they hear me in the flesh is like
when they can really tell that there's
an accent that's weird
what if you're just extra good or that
day maybe you're trying to wrap the hood
Joel uh it's way definite chicken err
maybe I don't know
[Music]